>>Student: This plan specifically
called for a transitional government
which would govern Iraq until
the elections would be held
in the summer 2005.
>>Narrator: This mock United Nations
caucus is part of the curriculum
at ISA, the International
School of the Americas.
>>Student: Every nation
in here would have a copy
of the coalition's timeline.
>>Narrator: At this magnet school in
San Antonio, Texas field trips begin
at the local museum, move
to the local mission,
and end in the interior of Mexico.
>>Shari: We asked the question,
could we use our proximity
to Mexico two hours away as an
international learning laboratory?
Could this become the
International School of the Americas
where kids were immersed
in global learning?
Could we do high schooling
differently?
Could we create a place that
felt personal and involved
where students' voice
was really important?
>>Student: I think community
also plays a role almost bigger
than religion.
>>Narrator: The ten-year ISA
experiment has succeeded thanks
in large measure to the
imagination of its teaching staff.
>>Kathy: When we have a new idea and
we say "Hey, I have this crazy idea,
we want to take 120 students
to Mexico for six days."
Many people would say
"What are you crazy?
We can't do that."
And here that type of out-of-the-box,
innovative thinking
is really encouraged.
>>Teacher: I think at this point
then, it's more important to get
as many ideas out on the table as
you can, so you got teen pregnancy-
>>Kathy: We've get kids who are
looking for something different.
Sometimes it's kids who want to be
more challenged more academically.
Sometimes it's kids who
want a smaller environment.
>>So will you talk a little bit
about what you were trying
to show in this image?
>>I think at this point
we've built this culture
where it is cool to be academic.
>>Narrator: To build the school
culture teachers work in teams
across disciplines doing whatever
it takes, even driving the bus.
>>Kathy: Unfortunately taking field
trips is expensive and we have
to pay our drivers and
it's very expensive.
And so I went and got my bus driving
license as did several other members
of our staff so that when we go on
field trips I can drive the bus,
and then it doesn't
cost the kids anything.
>>Narrator: At ISA every
field trip is a focused,
interactive learning experience
that links the classroom
with the outside world.
>>Linda: These particular
masks were used for what?
>>Student: Religious purposes?
>>Linda: So much of what
you see, you learn from.
On a trip out of the country
you learn every moment.
If we can use that learning and
incorporate it into what we're trying
to do then it enriches what
we're doing in the classroom
and it makes the experience
more whole.
>>Teacher: When we go to
Monterey I believe we're going
to go to the museum there.
You're going to see many
portraits of monjas coronadas.
>>Narrator: ISA has become a
professional development school
for nearby Trinity University giving
their student teachers a global
perspective on learning.
>>Student: The purpose was
it's like the focal point
of the costume for a dance drama.
>>Angela: We're creating this
idea in our beginning teachers
that you are a teacher not only
in the classroom but a teacher
of the world, that you are
an expeditionary teacher
who takes students out into the
world to learn a little bit.
It's very intense, it's very
challenging to travel with students
but the benefits curricularly,
intellectually, socially,
emotionally, are immeasurable.
>>Student: I'm Captain Kelly
Mason of the United States Navy,
and I'm here today on leave to join
you today in this town meeting.
>>Narrator: While a typical high
school American History lesson might
focus on dates, this turn
of the century town meeting role
play teaches context and tolerance.
>>Student: We've been chosen by God
for greatness and it is our job,
it is our duty and
our obligation to go
to these troubled heathen-filled
countries and teach the Word of God
and to teach them how to be educated.
>>Student: I think really
the economical standpoint
and all the trading would be
what we'd have to focus on
and not all the moral
standpoints because I don't know
if that's really going to
help the United States.
>>John: The idea that they have
a voice that they're expected
to vocalize for themselves, I
think encourages that ability
to speak up, to be heard.
>>Student: It's the same issue,
different presidents,
different countries.
>>John: And then I think the skill is
also developed to sit back and listen
to others and not always have to be
in the forefront of what's going on.
>>Student: A lot of my good
friends have totally different views
than I do.
And before I was just like I had no
idea like "Why would you think that?"
But after this simulation and
past simulations that I've done,
now I understand why they think
that way, even though I don't agree,
at least I understand why.
>>Student: The coalition forces
have had a lot of problems
with the Islamic militant
groups in Iraq.
>>Narrator: To help students
understand and accept the views
of people around the globe ISA
established a Model United Nations
program sponsored by the city
of San Antonio the group hosts an
annual convention and participates
in other Model U.N.
gatherings around the world.
>>Elizabeth: All those
wishing to speak to the pro,
please raise your placards:
China, United States.
>>Russell: There is
intensive academic research.
There is intense writing involved.
There is important
interpersonal skills that kids have
to really learn how to work with
each other in a diplomatic fashion
and that's something that's not- does
not come natural to the teenager.
>>Student: Motion unmoderated
caucus for ten minutes.
>>Narrator: Every ISA sophomore
takes a class that prepares them
to act as a country's delegate.
>>Student: All closed.
>>Narrator: And some students elect
to continue their Model
U.N. experience
in a club that meets after school.
>>Elizabeth: So one
year I represented Iran
and Iran's official position at the
time was not my official position
on women, I can tell you, so by
using Model United Nations as a tool,
you can teach students
to take the position
of a country whose views may
not necessarily be their own.
>>Student: We need
to foster that idea
of local government
at the root which-
>>Elizabeth: I've seen students
come out of their shells,
learn to speak eloquently,
succinctly,
and to think on their feet and
know when their ideas are good
and should be heard and know when to
shut their mouths which is something
that real professionals
need to do sometimes.
>>Student: The United States
considering the topic we're here
to debate doesn't feel the
need to answer that question.
>>Shari: I think they graduate
with an emotional intelligence
and that's really important
for success in our world today.
They're very savvy at understanding
group dynamics and I think that's one
of the most important
gifts they walk away with.
I think they also walk
away as learners.
It is very cool to be smart
here, and our students walk
out the door believing that.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to edutopia.org.